[Musique]
bonne soirée à tous bonne soirée à
toutes les familles beauchamp sont très
heureux de vous présenter le jeu de la
première chaîne réponse à tout et voici
si vous le permettez
les premiers concurrents de ce premier
match alors moi je vous présente mais
c'est george rivaux qui est le candidat
que je manage vous habitez paris
non noisy-le-grand dans la seine seine
de la seine saint denis quel est votre
profession professeur d'histoire
géographie au lycée de nos jours on sait
en pleine forme
mon point fort c'est très bien monsieur
peillon vous n'êtes plus professeur vous
étiez cependant dans l'enseignement il
ya quelques temps
cet examen vous avez pris votre retraite
il y en un peu plus d'un an et où
enseigne et vous aussi aux jets de nuit
sur scène mais ce n'est pas même vous
inviter monsieur où j'habite paris
iiième arrondissement et mieux je vous
souhaite bonne chance
la règle du jeu elle est très simple
vous allez vous opposez messieurs en un
match amical mais serré néanmoins avec
des questions extrêmement variés posées
par les téléspectateurs qui vont essayer
de vous coller et celui de vous deux qui
aura gagné le plus grand nombre de
points sera proclamé champion du jour il
reviendra le lendemain
affronter un candidat d'une ville
voisine voilà c'est clair ces trucs là
pour essayer de les déterminer celui qui
a ras la première chance de répondre à
la première question
nous allons procéder à un tirage à la
courte paille ou plutôt un tirage à la
courte flashy c'est très lourd je vous
dis tout de suite
monsieur peillon quelle sera la flèche
gagnante la longue ou la courte lacourte
là vous vous avez gagné c'est donc vous
mesurez vos qu'ils allaient commencer
tout de suite ce jeu l'inaugurer avec la
première question est moins bon monsieur
rivaux alors c'est une question qui va
vous être aux bruits qui va vous être
posée par un téléspectateur que vous
allez choisir vous même c'est une
question à 40 francs vous allez monsieur
rivaux voir apparaître sur votre écran
trois visages
trois visages de téléspectateurs et vous
allez faire votre choix
l'une de ces personnes que le cameramen
sont allés filmer chez elle va vous
poser une question à laquelle vous
devrez répondre en moins de 30 secondes
pendant ces trente secondes vous pourrez
donner autant de réponses que vous le
désirez si vous n'avez pas trouvé la
bonne réponse
la parole passera à votre adversaire oui
vous avez bien compris monsieur peillon
rétention vous n'aurez droit vous qu'à
10 secondes et vous n'aurez droit donné
qu'une seule réponse si vous gagnez
comme je l'espère eh bien vous gagnerez
40 francs sinon eh bien nous enverrons
ses 40 francs aux téléspectateurs qui
vous a posé la question
la série vaut quelques l île âge quelle
photo choisissez vous je choisis la
première photographie
la dame élégante aux yeux noirs vient et
aux cheveux blonds photo numéro une
[Musique]
cette fois cette question vous est posée
par madame claude
or tu qui habite paris m'a l'amorti
exerce un métier bien agréable mais ses
rivaux puisqu'elle est étalagiste
d'ailleurs nous la voyons en train de
préparer une devanture
alors écoutez bien la question que vous
vous posez
madame claude or tu te trouves tous sur
la plupart des tables moment de groupe à
qui sert à couper et qui n'est ni un
couteau ni un objet tranchant
ni une partie de votre individus vous
avez bien compris mais j'ai très bien
compris
top du sert à couper qui n'est ni un
couteau ni un objet tranchant
ni une partie de votre individus vous
avez 30 secondes vrai la carafe d'eau
bravo monsieur rivaux vous allez gagner
c'est exactement la réponse que
souhaitait le madame claude or tu car
elle sert à couper le vin vous avez
gagné donc 40 francs qui s'inscrit tout
de suite à votre compteur mais ne vous
affolez pas monsieur peillon ou
gagnerait certainement la seconde
question vous avez choisir l'un de ces
questionnaires je choisis la faute au
numéro 3 numéro 3
[Musique]
c'est également une question à 40 francs
qui est proposé par monsieur paul caron
de paris monsieur paul caron a été
filmée chez lui au milieu de ses
collections de deux vieux phonographe et
de vieux disques chez eux car on est
d'ailleurs aussi ce que je vais vous
faire entendre a été enregistrée par une
très grande vedette de cinéma
enfin vedette de cinéma maintenant parce
qu'à ce moment-là il s'adonnait surtout
à l'opéra et il créa en 1930 à celle
lupin banquiers de la tess et mirande
écouter
[Musique]
eh bien je voudrais savoir quel est le
nom de ce comédien c'est difficile c'est
difficile on croyait le reconnaître non
je ne pense pas top chrono images le
disque gratte un peu évidemment oui vite
annonce et enregistrements qui datent 78
ans n'a plus l'habitude d'entendre c'est
oui mais zone alité devrait vous aider à
cerner le personnage
ces jeux je ne vois pas passer demain
pourtant je suis sûr vous le connaissez
très bien vous avez de chance une seule
réponse 10 secondes vous êtes prêts top
je ne sais pas non plus il assez cherché
bien mais si vous savez sur moi c'est un
comédien très connu à traîner freiner
non hélas non et bien alors nous allons
demander à monsieur paul caron de donner
lui-même la bonne réponse il n'ya rien
que ça comme solution jean gabin qui
avait commencé comme chanteur
fantaisiste et l'était d'ailleurs à
bonne école puisque son père lui même
était une vedette du café concert mais
que ceci ne vous désespère pas 90 c'est
pas grave tout peut encore être gagnée
puisque nous arrivons maintenant à la
question à 60 francs vous connaissez
maintenant le processus monsieur revo
vous allez choisir parmi les trois
photos qui vont vous être proposées
celle qui a votre préférence
je choisis la seconde photographie la
seconde face à grasse
[Musique]
et bien c'est une photo qui vous est une
question plutôt qui vous est proposée
par mademoiselle françoise gilbert qui
habite paris
mademoiselle de françoise gilbert et
secrétaire à paris et malgré cela elle
va retrouver sa tante qui tient un café
vous avez vu notre enseigne
pourquoi beaucoup de bureaux de tabac
font-ils comme celui ci allant feignent
de la civette
vous avez bien compris la question j'ai
très bien compris oui alors top la
civette 30 secondes autant de questions
vous le voulez oui
et malheureusement je ne vois absolument
chercher encore je confesse mon manque
de curiosité parce que vraiment c'est un
nom en effet très fréquent pour les
tabacs vous ne savez pas non je ne fume
guerre je suis un très mauvais clients
attention tant pis non je ne sais pas
monsieur peillon connaissez vous
l'origine de cette civette top chrono
je pense qu'il s'agit d'un petit animal
qui produit une substance odorante
musqués bravo monsieur peillon autrefois
en effet le tabac et surtout le tabac à
priser et est parfumé à la civette
parfum provenant de cet animal qui
portait ce nom
voilà pourquoi tant de bureaux de tabac
ont cette enseigne la civette est bien
aussi une civette kivu rapporte en tout
cas 60 francs bravo monsieur peillon
voulez vous tenter une deuxième question
et 60 points et choisir parmi ces trois
photos
oui je choisis la faute au numéro 3
numéro 3
[Musique]
le numéro 3 et le général simon qui
habite dans l'oise à et nos villes nous
allons retrouver vingt général ciment
qui s'attache à l'avant de la faire ne
sorte que les charges liées à ses jambes
qui repose sur la partie tuez les par
vous voyez ici pendant de chaque côté de
la poule a du coup du chapeau
ici vous avez un fauteuil démontable à
l'aube chez decca pis pour les chefs
bédouins il se transporte facilement sur
la base d'un chameau il se démotiver
vous montrez comores
voilà qui peut se par conséquent se
charger facilement sur un chameau au
moyen de cordage et ceci m'amène à vous
demander
l'origine du mot camelot merci mon
général à vous monsieur peillon top je
suppose que la camelote désigné à
l'origine d'un tissu en poil de chameau
et que par la suite on a global sous
cette dénomination des objets assez
divers notamment ceux qui étaient
destinés à être vendus dans des pays que
nous appellerions aujourd'hui sous
développée par des marchands ambulants
en effet qu'on appelait des camelots à
cause de cette camelote qui à l'origine
était comme vous l'avez dit à base de
points de chameau et qui par la suite
est devenu un poil de chèvre en tout cas
c'est une excellente réponse une autre
excellente réponse qui vous vaut à
nouveau 60 francs et par conséquent
votre gain est à présent certainement de
120 francs tous mes compliments
monsieur revo vous allez faire aussi
bien j'en suis absolument convaincu et
le poids sont maintenant à une question
à 80 francs alors attention parce que
les choses se corsent encore une fois
trois photos vous choisissez celles que
vous désirez je choisis la troisième
photographie ça ne m'étonne pas de vous
c'est une question qui vous est posée
par madame geneviève b dei qui habite
paris dans le 17ème arrondissement
madame b dei à vous allez le voir un
charmant animal gesell regardez le bien
il louche comme clarence vous savez le
lion fétiche du feuilleton daktari mais
cela n'empêche pas madame b dei de vous
poser maintenant une question que vous
avez bien écouter car elle vous 80
francs julie victoire daubié fut la
première femme à remporter le 6 août
1861 une épreuve classique lequel
épreuve s'agit-il
mesurez-vous ça c'est une question que
vous devez connaître
vous avez bien compris non je n'ai pas
très bien entendu alors je vous le
rappelle julie victoire daubié fut la
première femme à remporter le 16 août
1861 une épreuve classique de quelle
épreuve
s'agit-il c'est clair maintenant oui
allez top je pense qu'il s'agit et d'une
épreuve de bicyclette
vous pouvez encore répondre vous avez
trente secondes c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça cherchez bien vous quel professeur
une épreuve une épreuve sportive
dépêchez-vous non c'est pas ça vite vite
vite une épreuve classique une épreuve
importante et classique
le concours général non monsieur je ne
sais pas non monsieur rivaux je vais
reposé la même question à monsieur
peillon connaissez-vous julie victoire
daubié top chrono
non à tout hasard je dirais que c'est il
s'agit d'un concours de sténographie g
produire quelque chose c'était pas mal
vous approchiez mais vous n'aviez droite
une annonce
ce n'est pas la bonne nous allons
demander cette réponse à notre charmante
candidats du baccalauréat
mademoiselle d'eau pied fut reçu à cet
examen à la faculté de lyon
comme le signale le procès verbal
mademoiselle daubié avait 37 ans
j'ajouterai que mademoiselle le baudier
pas ça se bat
lauréat avec la mention passable
aujourd'hui est que vous n'ayez pas su
cela en tout cas madame d'aidé y recevra
l 80 francs puisqu'elle a réussi à
coller nos deux concurrents de réponse
est et nous en arrivons maintenant à la
dernière question la question va tout
mais mais mais seulement un de nos
concurrents messier paille on peut
espérer demandé le bateau puisqu'il a
gagné une somme supérieure à 60 francs
somme mais de nouveau expliqué eh bien
le va-tout c'est la remise en jeu de vos
biens vous avez gagné monsieur paillon
120 francs si vous tentez le va tout
vous risquer de tout perdre certes mais
si vous donner une réponse vonn une
seule bien sûr en moins de 30 secondes
vous pouvez gagner 1000 francs par
conséquent que décidé vous tentez vous
le va-tout je tente le va-tout bravo je
n'en attendais pas moins de vous
monsieur peillon voici dont trois
nouvelles photos vous avez choisir votre
questionnaire je choisis la faute au
numéro un numéro un
[Musique]
le numéro un et monsieur morel qui
habite à paris dont le sixième
monsieur morel est antiquaire décorateur
rue bonaparte ou c'est aussi une petite
cafetière qui nous permettait de faire
qu'une seule tasse de café
quel nom lui donner temps alors non
malheureusement trop répandue
aujourd'hui
connaissez-vous cette quartier copte non
je ne connais pas d'ailleurs si on ne
m'avait pas dit que c'était une
cafetière j'aurais cru que c'était une
aiguière un oui c'est un tour
d'antiquaires voyez oui oui en effet
donnez moi des réponses monsieur non en
fait non non non malheureusement trop
répandue nous a dit monsieur morel
donc je ne vois
monsieur revo nous avons toutes nos
chances alors je me lève je vais lever
un verre vous vous voyez monsieur
monsieur peillon a perdu tous ces gars
puisqu'il n'a pas pu répondre à la
question va tout donc vous vous
retrouvez avec 40 francs et vous pouvez
à ce moment-là espérer gagner répondre à
cette question vous ne gagnerez bien
entendu que 85 mais c'est mieux que rien
vous êtes prêts oui top une je pense et
une cafetière monotone et bien non
malheureusement ce n'est pas la question
ce n'est pas la réponse que nous
attendions alors nous allons la demander
à monsieur morel tout simplement c'est
mimi 4 hier à deux tours nous l'égoïste
eh bien oui comme vient de nous le dire
monsieur morel 7 min cafetière du xviiie
siècle s'appelait l'égoïsme et tout ça
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'on
pouvait servir qu'une seule tasse de
café alors définitive monsieur rivaux
bien c'est vous qui vous retrouvez le
gagnant puisque vous avez encore 40
francs et oui sans gloire
ben c'est toujours mieux que rien alors
nous vous attendons si vous voulez bien
demain pour un autre jeu réponse à tous
nous comptons sur vous mais vous pouvez
compter sur moi et oui je plains
monsieur peillon qui a été victime d'un
égoïste ce qui est bien triste au moment
dé et rhein à demain au revoir
[Musique]